okay let's do it great all right
[Laughter]
okay okay that's the Moment of Truth my
friend yeah
okay
[Music]
so is everyone clear on what we're doing
today uh ranking dick sizes perfect I
think we all agreed
your eyes your eyes man just something
about them you look like a porn star bro
so I'm gonna say that you the biggest
all right now we think is the smallest I
don't know you have a lot of confidence
oh wait no no the smallest
next biggest so even though I'm black
don't think that that's just nothing to
do with it
I put myself in the middle Ware you know
it's like there's
some reason I think that tall dudes
might be a little more packing and
what's the shoe size
I feel like you should slide down a
little bit that's not the shoes I will
say I have seen some little like smaller
folks who are really packing so I don't
really don't know what to expect though
man but I think because y'all been more
bulkier I think y'all might be a little
bit more packing give me give me give me
a try give me a try
what do you say
number one sorry don't get offended
you come here
you go for number three you go for like
numbers I think he knows what is the
goal for number four where do you want
it you go there all right how do you
know what makes you think like what
makes you think like what's your bottom
or where do you think you stand amongst
the group me yeah what do you think I
can put myself though so where do you
think you stand it's not up to me it's
up to you to decide I think you should
just stay there I'm vulnerable
I think the two of you should switch at
the very least though
hey take it take it take it take the win
so I have a question for you who do you
think would be back because this we got
a ring the two that we have is the
smallest I would say probably they're
low-key they're not talking a whole lot
I'll say y'all too at least in the
middle cause y'all a bit more happy I
don't think I belong at the other end
though well damn that's a point here
I'll take one for the team and go to
this side so that no one has to
do you have any input on this
I think I think I belong maybe in the
middle to be honest so I'm gonna slide
between maybe y'all too I don't know
maybe after you actually oh wow okay all
right everybody's a little
self-conscious
okay all right
sure looks good okay perfect
[Music]
I feel like that's a bad place man I
don't think you should be at the at the
very end I'll just say uh I can uh
suck my own dick so I would say I don't
belong here that could be a flexible
thing yeah
I got one what's the longest
relationship everyone's been in for me
five years okay what about your longest
was like two and a half all right mine
was five years what about you guys six
years six years five years not
recyclable
it depends
depends if you ask me or you ask my
partner
well that solidifies our kind of like
Bachelors over here on this end is you
know somebody's gonna lock it down with
somebody who's got that consistent voice
you know what I mean Define boyfriend
it's honestly going to be on the smaller
end
oh so because I've been in a
relationship for five years I got a
small dick okay
someone slides you in front of me
because I got that SBC all right but I'm
not gonna lie though
now that we've had him there for a
minute that's a little sus it's like a
big point so let's be real here he's in
first place because we think he [__] you
know what I mean are you freaking what
do you mean do you get a lot of sex
taking sex a lot I had the sex before I
came to set oh there you see what I mean
I'm good with him there yeah
what is a five to six inches is a big or
a small one well five and a half is
average for Americans I want to move you
up no you want to switch right I think
him and I might be able to and I still
gonna change between you and him me and
him yeah cool wait but you're dude
you're definitely well I I disagree
I will say just to add this little twid
bit I remember some years ago there was
a girl that I was really attracted to we
ended up messing around right
and I was thinking damn if only I was
bigger go for a second go for a second
you gotta feel defeated but that's the
only time in my life I felt defeated I
just realized I can't handle everything
and I I admit that that's fair happens
to us all I mean because of that honesty
though
I might just push you a little bit like
towards three I mean has anybody else
here felt defeated before
honestly no I'm usually I'm I'm proud
you might be proud but were they proud
yes
nine times out of ten both parties left
happy
um so then to the question of does like
does size matter well as a gay man I
always say that I'm not a size queen I'm
a penile proportion Queen you can have a
small but really pretty dick right and a
big dick is can just be like a massive
gargantuan honking thing right there's
beauty in all penises is what I like to
say that was deep
very poetic well actually that makes me
think of something interesting we have
like the three shortest guys as the I
noticed three biggest oh yeah there's
like a stereotype in the gay community
that like small like small skinny guys
always have like a honk and third thing
because like they don't go to the gym so
all their energy and food goes to that
instead okay I have the same size penis
since I'm fourth grade
where are you gonna put me now what if
he has a micro penis what if we have
we're ranking him as the biggest Dickies
wow there's beauty in all things yes you
say that well yeah I mean did you hit
puberty like fourth grade no
I wasn't your man so there's no way in
that case
yeah in that case I would probably put
you a little bit more here I'd probably
put you next to me next to you yeah yeah
we're switching it up and I think you
should slide because you wouldn't feel
defeated my friend
right here I'm cool man I'm cool can you
speak about the pressure to be bigger uh
personally I've never faced
I don't feel that no I don't yeah I I
didn't feel pressured until today
I think there's a lot of a lot of
pressure to impress and you know even a
personal pressure and a confidence boost
true you know yeah it's a societal thing
I mean like growing up if there's not a
lot of sex education in schools so you
learn a lot of stuff either from like
porn or like other things like that and
basically yeah you shouldn't learn it
that's right that's the goal of this of
this video but I think
at least I'm I'm from Israel so it's
very close-minded we're not talking
about sexuality or sex so porn and this
is the number one mistake because Ponies
are comparing completely fake it's very
bad to compare yourself or look into
prone to to see what to do how to do it
should be around communication with your
partner and yeah all penises are
gorgeous the way they are has anyone
done any sex work
of the newborn yeah
put you next to me
he's an acrobat over here you know
because of that I'm gonna go into third
and I feel like you should be in second
what does everyone else do I work in I.T
I'm a I'm an investor well you gotta
have you know big you don't need a big
dick to make money
I'm a nurse so in all honesty working in
the hospital you have to like clean them
and everything I've seen a lot of
penises everybody's about the same like
size because you've seen so many dicks
where do you feel like you fall in the
spectrum of penises you don't see them
erect so technically I can still be
wrong but I would put myself maybe at
like a little bit like
bigger than okay but like I wouldn't say
a lot yeah what so you said what do we
do like what do the rest of you guys do
yeah I'm a chef I own an escape room I
mean yeah I mean someone taking this L
and I don't mind taking it right now bro
I mean it's um you know I'm Asian you
know I'm half asian so it's uh it's
understandable if you guys think
something about it where y'all want me
just let me know now number three I say
three three three
yeah three four number two does anyone
feel like they don't belong where they
are yeah I think you're confident
I think I'm number two man
I like it that's so good I think this
yeah I I like this I like this you're
locking it in yeah we're locking it in
okay
any questions before we get started
no not to do it yeah great all right
okay okay that's the Moment of Truth my
friend yeah all right
okay
[Music]
oh man
he said awesome
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay thank you
thank you
we're going to start with the ranking
for the soft length sizes
so
seventh
Andy
sixth Asher
[Music]
number two
fifth Baron
fourth Giovanni
[Music]
okay
Tanner
we knew this was coming no no second
David yes
yes
that kind of makes sense starting with
Andy can you share your soft length size
uh 2.5 uh 3.2 3.5 4 also four 4.5
12.5 okay I'm just my man over here I'm
just highly impressed right now
man
I was thinking all right we're going to
move on to what we've all been waiting
for the hard length sizes in seven Andy
in sixth Baron oh all right
in fifth
Asher
NBC
[Music]
[Laughter]
third Giovanni
hmm
in second Tanner
and in first Jessie but we knew this we
caught it from the beginning
it was wrong just about you the rest was
exactly Mr Big Dick Energy
can you start with your hard length size
4.8 we are going to hand you a cucumber
that is cut to your size
[Music]
[Laughter]
can you hold it up it's a beautiful
piece
[Laughter]
six just for me
um
[Music]
six cheers
[Laughter]
6.3 nice and thick little sword cucumber
6.5
wow
seven oh my God oh my God
eight yeah okay baby
okay how's everyone feeling now
I'm happy yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
and let's do a quick circumference size
rearrangement
[Music]
big dick is a curse as well don't forget
it it's not wrong you were talking about
the boyfriend dicks do you guys feel
like talking about size so openly has
maybe really some pressure or taboo
surrounding the subject yeah because
it's dumb it's like just talking about
it it's like clearly no one actually
cares like I mean and if there is any
kind of actual care like it's
it's like we all know it doesn't matter
and and I will say it's just a stupid
stigma about oh you got to have big dick
as long as you know what you're doing I
think you straight you know what I mean
so that motion in the ocean like this
yes good job guys cheers
hey guys Jason from Jubilee here you
might be wondering why in the world did
Jubilee make this video uh we have a lot
of reasons but we hope that you'll head
over to tubali to actually listen to a
breakdown on the thinking and the
chemistry and the behind the scenes of
all this so we'll see you there soon
Logan as our Medical Professional do you
have anything you want to add any input
I've never seen so many penises in one
day
would you like this cucumber